when would you say was the first time
that you saw Dragon Ball Z with a 19 I
think my earliest memory that I can
recall right now was when I was on
holidays in America and we were watching
TV and I saw an ad for Dragon Ball Z and
I remember thinking I've heard of this
when I was younger
you got like a ton of small dragon wall
toys and when my friends come over he's
like there's a little thing I was
watching the ad literally I was only
like eighth 19 I was nine years old time
and even as a stupid 9 year old I was
watching this and I was like this looks
stupid I don't like this at all
I'm glad I don't watch this and now I
know it was like kinda wrong like well
no I was right it is stupid but like you
know it's cool it's fun it wasn't as bad
as 9 year old man you thought it was as
it currently stands Dragon Ball super is
a hugely lucrative property and is
arguably the most profitable IP owned by
Toei animation studios and Shueisha
today however it hasn't always been that
way
following the room the franchise had in
the 80s and 90s was always going to be
an uphill struggle but I doubt many
anticipated the UPS the downs the
controversy and the backlash the series
received on his journey to meet that 100
episode milestone in 2015 the Dragon
Ball series reemerged after a 17 year
long hiatus to meet a very different
anime industry one that had played a
leading role in influencing for better
or worse now we've got a lot to cover
video games merchandise production
animation story ratings and manga I'm
here to cover it all today and to
chronicle the events that serve to build
the platform Dragon Ball super currently
stands upon this is Dragon Ball super
100 episodes later
you
at the time I
of yugioh and i remember looking for
like to see a few heroes on because it
would normally be around on that time
and I remember going on and it was like
the first time I ever saw dragon ball i
think was Goku and piccolo over his
rabbits so oh Jesus that's a long time
ago never I was in China it was pretty
normal thing because the posters faster
all over China likes pretty popular I'm
gonna start washing it and our number
was brony it was that that was the first
one like I ever watched with the manga
having come to a close in 1995 after 11
years of publication the brass behind
the Dragon Ball licensing endeavoured to
create an anime only continuation to the
Dragon Balls story this idea led to the
creation of 1996 is Dragon Ball GT
however this venture didn't exactly turn
out to be the roaring success Toei
animation studios wanted from its former
top property and so on November 19 1997
on Fuji TV Dragon Ball GT aired its
final episode episode 64 only a year and
a half into its production on that same
year Dragon Ball GT final bout for the
PlayStation was released and again two
lackluster sales selling a disappointing
two hundred and seventy thousand units
worldwide with an exhausted akira
toriyama stepping away from Dragonball
entirely and GT having signaled the end
of the series it looked as though Toei
animation had to put the literal and
proverbial pen down with the once highly
successful Dragon Ball franchise toy
animations Dragon Ball Department had
its doors closed indefinitely ensuring
that not only was there not going to be
a continuation of the Dragon Balls story
but for the first time in over ten years
no plans were made for future Dragon
Ball video games for any console this
was made even more jarring jus in no
small part to the fact that during the
11 years prior from 1986 to 1997 the
Dragon Ball franchise had produced 23
officially licensed video games
averaging over two games a year however
while the Japanese public was turning
its attention away from Dragon Ball
6,000 miles away on the other side of
the planet
Dragon Ball was gathering more attention
introducing itself to a brand-new young
audience
you
we had like three channels or something
at my house and so one time we were at
my granny's and she had like satellites
which was big at the time and the the
first time you my two brothers saw
anything even like Dragon Ball Z like we
only watched like Eddie and Eddie and
all that kind of crack but the first
time we saw Dragon Ball Z was at her
house and it was the episode where go ku
is fighting the g10 he's like the giant
monkey guy a long time ago I think it's
actually my friends playing it that I
first was introduced to it and then I
got interested in anime and wanted to
watch it because a lot of my friends
started watching the coercion the short
fat guy with the sword cuts off his tail
like there was like six episodes or
something in a row that we watched all
right this is the most amazing thing
I've ever seen in my life in 1994 a
company called Funimation productions
headed by Gann Fukunaga acquired the
rights to dub into English and broadcast
the original Dragon Ball in syndication
through a connection with an uncle
working in toy animation in 1995 the
decision was made to begin production on
a Dragonball Z dub for North America
Funimation collaborated with Saban
entertainment to finance and distribute
the series to television and contracted
ocean studios in Canada to dub the anime
into English with Funimation overseeing
the dubs production ocean Studios cast
listing was as follows
Peter Columbus took on the lead role of
Goku with Brian drum and taking on the
role of Vegeta Gohan was saffron
Henderson piccolo scott mcneil Booma
Maggie blue O'Hara and Terry Klassen
filled the role of Crillon many of you
might remember Bryan Drummond's
performance as the Vegeta was coined the
term over 9000 Brian Drummond is a god
I'm not really a dub guy like III
appreciate some of the stuff they do
with Chi by just I'm not I'm not big on
it but like Brian Drummond is a
phenomenal Vegeta and scott mcneil there
are basically no English actors I go hmm
you're probably probably better than
your Japanese counterpart and as much as
I love furukawa's piccolo Scott McNeil
is so [ __ ] good because he just he
captures that demonic side of piccolo so
well I sat down and I started trying to
watch the ocean cast and and the the dub
that I'd grown up with and within like
five episodes I was like wow this is
really dated this is not
is not working for me there are nice
moments here and there but this is not a
show for adults certain changes were
made to the show to help cater for an
english-speaking audience and a younger
demographic these changes included the
were limited to the editing of the first
67 episodes down to 53 the removal of
any mentions of the word death replacing
it with terminology like the next
dimension and removing any overly
violent moments with digital touch-ups
Dragon Ball Z first hit American screens
in the fall of 1996 however it wasn't
until the fall of 1998 that Dragon Ball
Z found the audience it was looking for
I am Jason DeMarco I am John Aikens on
the original creator of genomic in 1998
Cartoon Network was trying to expand and
build a block that primarily consisted
of American animation and Japanese anime
DBZ came on at like 5:30 in the morning
on channel 69 in Atlanta and kids were
setting their alarm and like waking up
at 6:30 on Sunday or whatever to watch
this crazy show and then my friend
started doing it so I was watching it
and then you would get bootleg VHS tapes
that was when I thought there could be
something here and if kids are willing
to get up this early on Sunday and watch
this show what if we put it on at 5
o'clock in the afternoon what could
happen and that's when it blew up what
was your favorite moment in Dragonball Z
I was on a family trip in France and I
found the deadzone movie on DVD at the
place we were staying in French and I
just remember watching it my dad was
there cuz he spoke French and there and
I remember he would like give me he
wouldn't like say in detail what
everyone's saying would he give me basic
stuff oh this guy said that that guy
said that and the one thing that would
always stuck with me for whatever reason
was when piccolo was fighting one of
garlic Center and I think his name was
Sancho when he hits him and he likes to
send them off to distance and he just
blast him there are so many good moments
like Vegeta sacrificing so it was a
great moment for his character
development like you could see that he
actually cares and he often puts up this
kind of wall where you know he wants to
be a proud Prince but he actually has
feelings part where going on
transformed where Android 16 got his
head crushed and just that scream along
with the music that was like hands down
that that's my favorite moment of like
the whole show or like when he was just
when he defeated so I'm like I'd start
when he was like 20 M after he had like
that really emotion at birth when Vegeta
like sacrificed himself to try and kill
Boo Boo's
[ __ ] [ __ ] so he just comes back
together anyway it was bad villain team
Gohan going super saiyan 2 is very near
and dear to me it's basically because I
main team Gohan in every Dragon Ball Z
fighting game that's yeah I put a lot of
thought into it instead of Rio being
saving this musical score that was
currently used for the ocean dub Andrey
contracting ocean dub services
Funimation would begin using their own
in-house talent based in Fort Worth
Texas USA to dub the rest of the series
from episodes 54 onwards many pages is
this strip approximately 600 is that
unusually long yes all the Godfather
movies script format maybe would maybe
would be this big maybe all the Star
Wars movies all six would be this big
the new cast included Shawn symbol as
Goku Christopher sabot as Vegeta
Stephanie Nadal me as Gohan Christopher
sabot again as piccolo Tiffany Vollmer
as Bulma and stunning straight as
Crillon here why don't I teach you a
thing or two about sans what you're
seeing now this is my normal state in
1999 season 3 of Dragon Ball Z with
Funimation's in-house dub was the
highest rated program ever at the time
on Cartoon Network by 2002 the week
ending September 22nd Dragon Ball Z was
the number one program of the week on
all of television with tweens 9 to 14
boys 9 to 14 and Men 12 to 24 with the
Monday Tuesday and Wednesday telecast of
Dragon Ball Z ranked as the top three
programs in all of television broadcast
or cable by 2003 Dragon Ball Z had
become a runaway success all across the
world what's important to note at this
point is that from JT's original
end in 1997 up until 2002 the only new
additions to Dragonball made by Toei for
licensing agreements that might not seem
like much but in doing so toy animation
licensed Dragonball to all of these
stations production companies and
businesses
this included revenue splits for toy
manufacturing game sales digital media
sales and the TV show itself translation
this meant that toy animation would
receive an agreed-upon slice of the
profits that all of these companies made
from releasing Dragonball in their
respective countries with the impressive
success Dragonball was seen outside of
Japan Shu a she decided it was time to
reopen the Dragon Ball property and
begin planning for the future not with
anime just yet but with a re-release of
the manga and a string of new video
games in 2002 for the first time in five
years the Brass behind Dragon Ball
finally released the new video game
officially licensed dragon ball z
budokai developed by Dimps corporation a
development studio based out of osaka
japan and produced by Bandai 2002 s
dragon ball z budokai was a roaring
monetary success on all fronts and was
the first time a Dragonball game had a
full European release selling almost 3.8
million units worldwide almost tripling
the former decades best-selling titles
and grossing 14 times more revenue than
Dragon Ball GT final bout for the
PlayStation the success emanating from
the release of dragon ball z budokai
encouraged the dragon ball license
holders to fund future dragon ball
projects due to 2002 s resurgence of
Japanese public interest in the Dragon
Ball property on December 4th of that
year she way she began to re-release the
original manga in a complete cunzhen bun
or perfect edition format the cons and
bond release condensed the original 42
volumes into 34 with each volume
containing approximately 15 chapters
unlike the tankobon
or the original release of the manga the
cons and bond retained all of the
colored pages originally printed in
Weekly Shonen Jump the main difference
between the two releases however new
artwork from Akira Toriyama was present
on each subsequent cover and the volumes
were slightly larger in size Akira
Toriyama also took it upon himself to
alter the ending of the story slightly
illustrating a few more panels and an
attempt to create a more satisfying
ending around the same time as the
release of the Dragon Ball cons endo
during the winter of 2002 it was
announced by Toei animation that the
entire 291 episode dragon ball z TV
series would be released on DVD spanning
two massive box sets known as the dragon
boxes the first 147 episodes of the
series were released in March of 2003
and the latter half in September of that
same year 2004 saw the box set released
for the original Dragon Ball TV series
2005 saw the release of GT and in 2006
we received a box set release of all the
movies much the same as when Dragonball
was at the height of his popularity in
Japan each subsequent year from 2002
onwards saw a new officially licensed
Dragonball video game each title
exceeded the sales of the former
decade's best
and despite Dragon Ball Z's run being
completed these video game releases
wouldn't reach their highest heights
until the release of 2007 of dragon ball
z budokai Tenkaichi 3 which sold over 4
million units worldwide this marked the
highest-grossing Dragon Ball video game
in history to help put this in
perspective budokai Tenkaichi 3 outsold
80% of all Tekken games 95% of all
Street Fighter games 95% of all Mortal
Kombat games every UFC game and every
boxing game including Mike Tyson's
punch-out and if we look specifically at
anime series that later produced video
games
Dragon Ball has been by far the most
successful surpassing one piece Naruto
attack on Titan and bleach his best
efforts I am by no means suggesting that
budokai Tenkaichi 3 is a better game
than any of the others listed above what
I am hoping to illustrate here is that
after Dragon Ball Z's boom in north
america the desire fans had for more
Dragon Ball was made abundantly clear
between 2002 and 2007 the Dragon Ball
franchise had sold over 16 point five
million games worldwide did you guys
play the Dragon Ball video games like a
[ __ ] I played all the Buddha
Kai's all the budokai Tenkaichi z-- team
Gohan all the way guys can go on I mean
from what I've seen they all look cool
but from what I've heard like some of
them are really bad and not the people
are like oh this series is the best of
all and everything after that is [ __ ]
and I literally have no opinion either
way
he looks cool though I was universe just
a bit of it though you could play you
know as a different character were you
you were there in the moment when things
happened from the episode so it was
really fascinating I looking into the
universe - I think that looks good and
drive do you see the Dragon Ball
fighters II or fighters ever I would
kind of all about that I I have the
Dragon Ball booboo tokaiya for a ps2 and
I was obsessed with that played
throughout three times got unlocked
everything I did you the fire and played
again I have friends who are like into
fighting games and they I remember that
I would used to prefer Raging Blast
budokai Tenkaichi games more 3d open
space ones and they'd always be like I
know the more like side view ones of
Budokai are kind of better and I
remember when I was younger I'd you
should be like what is this this is this
is dumb but then I actually play a bit
of those games fairly recently and I was
like all exists actually it's just
better mate I used to play a beauty k2
and I remember because when we first got
it we didn't have a memory cage or it
didn't work on our ps1 so we'd have to
like I would literally like pause it and
we'd go away for like errors and I'd
come back and I'd like snap if the TV
like turned off or something oh I loved
it I thought there was like it would
meet your expectations but more like
there was never like you can level 9000
he's like the highest level and then
like all sudden it's like a billion and
doesn't even matter anymore why was it
was Larry as I loved it
my older brother had got one of the
newer ones for Christmas a couple of
years ago and himself and my younger
brother were kind of players and they
were fighting amongst themselves on us
and I was I think I was building like a
Lego Death Star or something because
that's what I do with my free time on
Christmas and they asked me like Eric
come on Jonah sit down and have a fight
with us yeah sure no worries i sat down
they both have a for a common virus
they're at this stage and I'd be both of
them my first go and Ani never played
the game again so I retired had a 100%
success rate with a newfound success of
dragon ball in the West and the
resurgence of popularity with a younger
generation in Japan thanks to the cons
and vine and the dragon boxes on the
21st of April 2008 it was announced on
Weekly Shonen Jump magazine that a new
OVA for dragon ball would be aired to
celebrate Shorin jumps 40th anniversary
this new installment in the
ball franchise saw the return of not
only all of our favorite characters to
the silver screen but for the first time
since 1995
series creator Akira Toriyama returned
to write the story
this new OVA was entitled yo son Goku
and his friends returned and so they did
return with brand new animation and a
familiar writing style to this date it
has yet to receive a wider Western
release however only being available in
its native Japanese language with
subtitles after the appraisal the OVA
received toy animation and Shueisha
wanted the momentum to continue
endeavouring to greenlight a new Dragon
Ball anime TV series in 2009 however
Akira Toriyama stood firm with his prior
convictions stating that he was done
with Dragonball still burnt out from the
decade he had dedicated to the material
in the 80s and 90s still wanting to fill
the Dragon Ball void that there was in
the Japanese market while trying to
avoid the commercial disaster that was
Dragon Ball GT towing animation decided
to begin production on a new project
watch Dragon Ball Z the way it was meant
to be seen Dragon Ball Z Dragon Ball Kai
was a high-definition remastered cut of
the original Dragon Ball Z TV series it
premiered on Fuji TV on April 5th 2009
at 9:00 a.m. just before 1 piece during
his two years syndication on Japanese
television Dragon Ball Kai consistently
appeared in the top 10 highest rated
anime TV series every week Dragon Ball
Kai was later dubbed and released in
numerous countries worldwide
again reintroducing and in some cases
introducing dragon ball to the public
eye however Dragon Ball Kai wasn't the
only dragon ball related property to be
released that year on March 13th and
April 10th 2009 20th Century Fox and
director James Wan brought Dragonball
Evolution to thousands of movie screens
across Asia and the Western world the
movie bombed critically receiving
negative to average reviews across the
board worldwide the website Rotten
Tomatoes gave the film a score of 14
percent based on 58 reviews before the
film's release Dragon Ball creator Akira
Toriyama initially felt surprised by
Dragonball Evolution and suggested to
his fans to treat it as an alternate
universe version of his work years later
in an interview with the Asahi Shimbun
Toriyama revealed that he felt the
Hollywood producers did not listen to
his ideas or suggestions citing that the
final version was not impaired
with the original source material
finally in 2016 while discussing the
film in the Dragon Ball 30th anniversary
super history book
Toriyama rose I had put Dragon Ball
behind me but seeing how much that
live-action film took me off Dragonball
Evolution ran in many theaters through
the summer of 2009 however Dragon Ball
Kai continued to air on TV screens all
over the world up until its 97th episode
on March 27 2011 we we watched Kai until
it was a favorite into the sell-side
it was like towards the end of the south
side we swapped over to Norman to normal
original Z we just kind of been to watch
it in period so like six seven of us
gets together get some food popcorn
cetera in someone's front room and just
watch about maybe seven episodes at once
go home in the morning
I enjoyed Kai a lot more because it
could s like a load of stuff but also
that means like there's a load of
character his the people talk about like
I don't know where that is because they
just don't exist to me because their Ark
was obviously not important at all on
July 21st 2012 during cycle V Jump Festa
a short teaser trailer announcing the
film Dragon Ball Z battle of gods was
shown and on March 30th 2013 Toei
animation studios released its
eighteenth movie Dragon Ball Z battle of
gods I feel like I feel like I have
memory of me hearing about it and then
like the next time I saw you going oh
yeah I was hyped because her GT was
disappoint did like you know I was on a
scale for any news with chart melon
sauce when they announced that I was
through I think my reaction was some
level of unnecessary like hugely excited
but I was like oh that's cool Dragon
Balls coming back and I then remember
seeing how mind-blowing Li excited
everyone else was getting and while I
doesn't necessarily have like that level
of excitement everyone outside I do
remember being like I'm glad that people
are getting so passionate about this
I saw it eight years ago I thought it
was awesome like the new characters that
we were introduced the character design
was it was completely different from
what we knew before so it was refreshing
but they kept the tone of Dragon Ball Z
so they kind of combined the two
together very well and I really loved it
they instantly I kind of brought out
this new kind of farm which was free
class because you look like if I turn
into like this young guy it was it was
it was I didn't like as much compared to
the whole series like John Ball Z but I
could still see was they didn't just
bring it back because they wanted to
make money if they actually had a good
idea and they wanted to make something
that was really good at the time it was
the best quality like I know that as an
animation wise I've ever seen Dragonball
yen this was the first new major feature
to come out of Dragon Balls since the
time GT was on the air back in the late
90s however unlike GT battle of gods had
one other vital added benefit it was
very very clear the Toriyama had
involvement with battle of gods because
that Goku on screen there was very very
different from what we've seen in the
past even even in Z which is obviously a
direct adaptation of the manga it just
felt so him the way that Goku acted and
responded the things it was like that
perfect blend of you know that that
childlike nature that everyone kind of
loves about Goku and then there was also
the serious side of things a lot of the
Dragon Ball movies had a formula in
which villain shows up Goku and his
friends fight the villain they struggle
Goku or somebody unleashes a powerful
attack or transformation to defeat the
villain within the last five minutes and
then they close and the plot doesn't
change at all afterwards and this was
the first time where it's like no
they're not defeating beerus they're
fighting him they actually lose
initially planning on staying distant
from the material itself after reading
the script and the details of the
character beerus he took it upon himself
to illustrate and alter the
characteristics of him this led to
further character designs script rial
Turing's and gags being written for the
movie before he knew it Toriyama had
found himself much more involved than he
had ever intended to think that
Dragonball Evolution widely considered
an in
to the japanese property played a
pivotal role in compelling Toriyama to
participate in the creation of another
Dragon Ball series the animation that
was showcased in the film was polished
but vastly different to what fans
recognized from the 90s this was a clear
indication that the animators from the
90s had all begun animators like Nikita
Tay masa Hiroshima nuki
Lyoto shi shi de and tell Yoshi Yamamoto
were some of the veterans that remained
from that golden era the latter of which
Thierry yoshiyama Mauro while once being
heralded as tOA's most proficient Dragon
Ball animator has since fallen from
grace once responsible for crafting some
of the most memorable scenes in the
series the long break from the franchise
has not been kind to his abilities this
wouldn't be as large an issue as I am
make here out to be if it wasn't for the
fact that during the production of the
movie battle of gods Yamamoto was
assigned the position of lead animation
director which afforded him the
authority to trace over the animation of
other younger talented animators this
allowed the movie to look as though it
was drawn by one individual Yamamoto
leading to scenes looking more
consistent aesthetically however some
have drawn attention to this fact
stating that it didn't matter how
talented the animators were under him it
was his style that Shaun threw for the
production of Dragon Ball Z Kai this
became commonplace many in the community
critiquing his modern work comparing it
to his earlier pieces this came to the
forefront of the industry however with
the release of the movie battle of gods
in 2013 when a popular young animator
named Yoshi Michiko Maeda famous for
producing key animation sequences in
shows like one punch man and Full Metal
Alchemist came out on Twitter is citing
his frustrations with Yama more oh I
can't hide my shock give me the soft
designs of the money that my normal
period during the 90s my ather miner who
was the man responsible for how Dragon
Ball Z's characters looked this man was
in charge of dictating what the
characters looked like by producing
character design sheets with which the
animators beneath him would use as
reference when drawing the characters in
the show Kameda was publicly
bad-mouthing the new character designs
supplied by yama mauro all of that aside
comments such as these didn't deter fans
from showing up in their droves to
support the movie and for it to be
overall critically acclaimed grossing 50
1.2 million u.s. dollars in the global
box office
30 million of which was achieved
domestically in Japan
as it stands Dragon Ball Z battle of God
sits as the 26th highest-grossing anime
all-time what would you say is your
favorite moment from battle of gods
favorite moment oh yeah it was the part
where Goku and Bureaus was under
underground and Goku Scott uh powers
running out and then just like he
screamed at that music he's charged at
beerus and that one yeah at Palmers
birthday party when beerus is there and
just like he's just interacting the
other one and it's like before the
actual fighting starts from the time
that he shows up to just his
interactions with everyone I found very
enjoyable
Goku's fighting beerus in the cave and
then he was like i'm not gonna let you
destroy my world you know and like he
who just goes mental that was beerus
kind of made like a huge blast I'm like
find a ton of them and Goku like was
like just dying I mean like literally
just did everything he could just to
destroy a vast and then when he did it
you were so happy he was like he almost
went about but then you realized you
could just tell how strong various was
compared to Goku animation and box
office receptionist side the most
important aspect to take away from this
release was its story and what it meant
for the future of the franchise the film
introduced us to the character beerus
and the position he holds in the Dragon
Ball world that position being the god
of destruction tasked with destroying
planets he deems as being unworthy of
remaining intact however the most
important piece of dialogue in the movie
comes during the final moments after
defeating Goku
beerus explains that he is the god of
destruction of this universe the seventh
going on to explain that this universe
folk who resides within is one of 12
universes with the others having spawned
warriors even more powerful than either
of them alongside introducing numerous
new characters Dragon Ball Z battle of
gods expanded the Dragon Ball world
unlike any other installment in the
franchise allowing room for new
interesting and dynamic stories to be
told which as it turns out wasn't that
far around the corner the success battle
of gods found and what it meant for the
franchise wasn't the only bit of good
news for Dragon Ball as I stated prior
Dragon Ball Kai was considered complete
with the ending of the cell saga
allowing room for the airing of a new
anime by the name of Torico however on
the 21st of February 24
the official Twitter account for the
Torico anime announced that the show
will end on March 30th after three years
shortly after it was revealed by Shui
Xiu's v-jump magazine that Dragon Ball
Kai will retake that timeslot beginning
April 6 9 a.m. on Fuji TV this
particular run for Kai was to bring the
series to completion and up-to-date with
the prior run of Dragon Ball Z and if
you'd believe it
Dragon Ball and now runaway train of
success had still more surprises in
store for its fans what did you guys
think of Resurrection f like I like this
but some of the moments in like to me
Frieza was dead ah I was really
disappointing with that like this is
pretty much is showing off a Super
Saiyan blue know that action was cool
cool and that's pretty much it but I
didn't really get as hyped like bringing
back Frieza was a complete like to me it
was complete just you know for marketing
me I very much enjoyed the resurrection
F song the theme song for Frieza but I
think just as an entry in this series
itself as a standalone film I think it's
a fun entry I think it's like a fun romp
but like I like the moment or a Madeira
got to beat the [ __ ] out of him finally
you know are you kind of wonder Vegeta
bunam because Vegeta always seemed to
hate him so much more than Goku barring
some bits with the CG ie the action is
like pretty well done the 18th movie to
be produced for Dragonball acted as the
continuation to the story brought forth
by battle of gods
this movie was Dragon Ball Z
resurrection F featuring the return of
one of the most iconic villains in the
history of the series Frieza wild
headline catching this move was met with
controversy some excited for the return
of the infamous character while others
meeting the announcement with a rolling
of the eyes it was fun to watch fun
fights fun animation don't get me wrong
and I love Frieza the film has a lot of
problems that has no second act the
story was not very good there's too many
unanswered questions there's too many
[ __ ] to put it very very simply as
someone who's now seen it a bajillion
times I can say that it's definitely not
a good follow-up to that film it felt
like a step backwards in so many ways
with battle of gods it expanded the
universe just exponentially with the
idea of gods of destruction and other
universes and this new godly power that
was that was like this is a new thing
and then resurrection F comes around and
it just shrinks everything again I
suppose the idea I don't want to sound
like every other fan but I can't lie
about this Vegeta should have been the
one to kill Frieza I like have a really
soft spot for Vegeta I he wants it so
but I think I spoke to news right before
he let Vegeta have it yeah [ __ ] Goku
with he's just oh I'm getting everything
all the time the dealer wants it more
than anyone else very passionate about
this resurrection F was released on
April 18 2015 grossing 65 million
dollars at the worldwide box office it
was clear that there was still a huge
amount of interest in this new Dragon
Ball property 10 days following the
release of their most successful movie
today's Towey animation issued a press
release that would shake the Japanese
anime industry
I think I was trying to find one-piece
episodes and then I got his website and
after watching that I just saw in the
corner Dragon Ball super I was at oh
they're making this area is I just saw a
bunch of pulse pop people talking like
oh there's gonna be a new Dragon Ball
anime and I just remember seeing people
getting like really excited but I
remember seeing that in thinking I was
probably some kind of like this probably
some kind of like joke or like April
Fool's thing that people are doing I
found you know I was really excited
again kind of like with Battle of God
that wasn't necessarily like hugely
excited I was like oh cool I wonder what
they'll do with it on April 28th 2015
Toei animation announced production of
Dragon Ball super the first all-new
Dragon Ball television series to be
released in 18 years set to debut July
5th 2015 this would immediately follow
the completion of Dragon Ball Kai's
finale the fact that it was coming so
soon was just kind of mind-blowing to me
it's funny it's funny looking back now
as someone who's aware of everything
that went on on the production side of
things that should have been massive
alarm bells going off but at the time at
the time it was just like oh my god is
two months away let's go whoa hypetrain
lets us do this
it had a very different story and that's
not necessarily a good or a bad thing
but it did have a very different start
to kind of to the rest of Dragonball
into a lot of other like shown in series
it was more child-friendly
and the animation sucked yeah the pilaf
game oh my gosh boy you're the day like
there's this she like no function for
them in the entire series except that
they try to do some of my knee and they
just fail anyway like there's nothing
like just nganimate and they're like
filler episodes would have them in it
and they'd have these tiny back straight
ends and I'm just like there's most
boring thing I've ever seen in my entire
life like how about you just like do
anything else and I'm happy yeah - to be
honest all I heard or just- like a read
article about how the animation is
jarring and how they're gonna fix it and
like the pool raise themselves but but
like the storyline it's you know
recapped from the movie so I just didn't
think of much playing the village's I
remember like seeing like everyone how
like hugely excited everyone was getting
but at the same time I do remember the
kind of nervousness that people had when
everyone found out that the first two
are could just be translating those
movies into arcs based some years after
the events of the Majin Buu saga of
Dragon Ball Z super picked up and
reintroduced the world to the colorful
cast of characters Dragon Ball had
assembled through the years with the
basic narrative covered in this parrot
being primarily the conflicts between
Goku and the newly introduced lord
beerus the god of destruction not an
obviously evil character with many
redeeming qualities beerus since its
unveiling in 2013 has become a fan
favorite
however despite many viewers enjoying
beerus this did not distract from the
fact that many had seen it before it had
now become abundantly clear Toei
animation had made the decision to cover
the last two movies released in the
first two arcs of Dragon Ball super
leading to many fans disappointment I
remember watching episode 1 and being a
little bit underwhelmed but because it
was the first episode of a new series I
kind of didn't feel like I could voice
that
Turner don't know how to explain that to
well but I it was almost like I couldn't
admit to myself that was kind of a bit
underwhelmed by that first episode I was
a bit underwhelmed by the fact that we
were we weren't really going into new
concert yeah the story lame Dragon Ball
super was presenting had a conclusion
many fans watching already knew despite
the vast majority of fans slating this
creative decision viewership held and
some praised the show for many fight
sequences during Goku's final
confrontation with beerus backlash over
repetition however was the least of Tony
animations problems with Dragon Ball
super premiere arc battle of guts
okay Goku not a fan of Japanese King Kai
he does not sound enough like Cartman
it's a very dynamic yes it's the voice
oh boy is not nice there's a lot of bad
art in this in this clip he looks much
different than I remember in that shot I
see Paris he doesn't know coke now Goku
is gonna stop holding back take off his
weighted undies yeah there is a like I
might be looking at it with nostalgia
goggles but I remember the fight seems
being crazy and Dragon Ball Z and in
that one there was an awful lot of like
static camera like it was just gonna the
one shot and characters moving around in
that plane well it looks like dated look
told him they what seasons that came out
about two years ago oh I mean I don't
know how much offer there was but I mean
watching it I would definitely say like
man it's that's pretty bad
the way I remember anyway is like you
know like cameras following fists and
punches and explosions and mountains
shattering when people scream and that
kind of stuff you know as far as like
your mane and Goku dancing around it's
not much so much afternoon there Goku
looks like an ugly man a lot of the time
there I mean I don't think I'd be wrong
saying Dragon Ball as a property is the
most well known anime ever around the
world so like you'd think that'd get a
bit more time like draw other drawings
yeah it wasn't there something weird
with that one as well they released like
a movie and a show and they were like
the same storyline same arc that seems
like it'll piss a lot of people off like
you're excited for the first new Dragon
Ball series and however long and it's
just rehashes of movies it got to the
point where just from a visual point of
view you could tell it was just bad like
you could look at the artwork you can
look at the movements like it didn't
take an
anime expert to realize how bad it was
I'm a casual person when it comes to
understanding the actual anime process
and yet I could dissect how bad this is
I think they rushed certain things like
I would like to know more about beerus
and whis you know but and like I'm not
100% a big fan of the pure comedy like
the amount of comedy that is being
thrown at you you know I prefer to have
a more serious theme I was really
disappointed because I dragged Mugsy
even though they have moments worth
animation is a bit off when in general
it's very fluid it really encapsulating
and especially having watching that show
for about like 10 or 20 times you know I
know every single moment of it like and
just this new started animation is
especially with the like that they got
rid of the edginess you know it just I
just loose off you know I think a lot of
the criticism that people were giving
Super's animation back then was very
very fair it was impossible to deny that
the show did not look very good I think
some of the stuff during the battle of
gods arc was probably overblown episode
5 aside which was obviously you know a
very very sore mark on the franchise
that I don't think has ever really gone
away somehow which is strange to me but
now I think my main issue with the
response that it got was mostly due to
how it was being reported it wasn't it
wasn't being reported accurately it
didn't seem like anyone was interested
in getting to the bottom of what
actually happened it was more just you
heard the same old tired incorrect
things about oh it's just budget low
budget all lazy animators not trying low
budget and it's just that's not that's
not what happened
Notah hero has Shiva producer act OE
though not one currently working on
super Stacy's in an interview with the
Anime News Network
the animators responsible for those
scenes are newbies who just started
working at this level in the industry
which means their skills are still
evolving right now hayashida claimed
that the quote bad animation in question
was the result of inexperienced
animators work coming under scrutiny
from the public that was what really
inspired me to investigate you know what
happened and actually reach out to you
know animators who were on that episode
these people do have twitter I remember
asking kenan suka who is the top credit
to the key animator on the episode i
said you know what happened with episode
5 and he just said in true vague
japanese fashion he just said there was
an animation breakdown
minions super staff worked on the
original series and others have at least
a decade of experience that said however
there are exceptions but they wouldn't
be prevalent enough to make an impact of
this magnitude but to understand this
properly we need to break down how
Dragon Ball super episode is created
making an episode is very difficult
before series like super premieres
usually half a year of pre-production is
required to create an efficient schedule
what do I mean by schedule a common
misconception within the animation
industry is that Toei animation makes
each episode of Dragon Ball super in the
week leading up to its airing meaning
when episode 1 ends on Saturday morning
they begin making the next episode right
after this is untrue so how does it work
Toei animation is an animation company
with many other shows other than Dragon
Ball super under its umbrella when
rights holders to Dragon Ball wanted
something to follow the end of Dragon
Ball Kai they decided to create a new TV
show called Dragon Ball super Toei
animation then creates a team of
animators to work on supers episodes you
with me so far
the members of Dragon Ball super
animation team are all subject to change
but they have remained relatively
consistent throughout supers run thus
far now this is where it gets a little
bit more complicated than many of you
might have anticipated each animation
department is broken into a hierarchy
and that looks a little like this right
at the top you have your supervising
director this position is usually held
by tadayoshi AMA Mauro his job is to
oversee and organize all of the
animation supervisors as well as key
animators for their given episodes
making sure that they finish on time
more on that time thing later he makes
sure that their animations are keeping
to the character sheets provided also
speaking of character sheets these
character designs for Dragon Ball super
were also done by mr. gamma Mauro who
has also filled the position of
character designer directly beneath the
supervising director we have the chief
animation supervisor more often than not
this falls onto mr. taki l-e day he has
overall responsibility for the quality
of the animated product which he
oversees now this could be a number of
episodes at a given time his job is to
aid in delivering consistent animation
on time and to screen it through yama
mora beneath the chief animation
supervisor we have the animation
supervisors finally we have arrived at
some actual animators familiar faces in
this
include Nikita Tay shuichiro Munnabhai
Massa Hiroshima nuki and Osama Ishikawa
one or two of these guys are assigned to
a given episode and alongside their key
animators and in-between artists work
towards producing their assigned
episodes for their deadline the
animation supervisors job is to maintain
the animation quality and to correct any
animation submitted to them by their
underlings to ensure consistency within
the episode they also provide key
animations think of these guys as the
bosses of each episode so if those are
the bosses of each episode there must be
people who work for them Enter key
animators which as the name indicates
work to create keyframes for animations
a notable figure within this role would
be Naoto chichi de who provide a key
animation for a portion of the beerus
goku fight in the movie battle of gods
the key animators usually are assigned a
portion of episode to animate by their
animation supervisor these portions
which are assigned are called cuts and
there could be as many as 300 cuts in a
given episode that's a lot of drawing
for those of you who are unfamiliar with
the term keyframes an animation is made
up of those key frames frames are the
drawings or illustrations provided by
the AI artists involved for example a
fully animated sequence might have as
many as 24 drawings or frames all of
these are not keyframes in order to
spread out work effectively key
animators draw the key frames these are
the most important shots in the animated
sequence which the viewer spends most of
their attention focusing on but I hear
you asking if the key animators only do
the important shots in the animation
what makes up the rest I'm glad you
asked but eat that again we have the
in-between artist who works to link the
key frames together using you guessed it
in between frames
combining these key frames with the
in-between frames creates a smooth
running animation cut but the real
question is how does this differ from
Dragon Ball Z's process on Z you would
have different teams as opposed to how
super works or it's kind of just like
independent supervisors for each episode
they're on their own rotation time the
animators under them aren't necessarily
on the same rotation time as their
supervisor so while the supervisor might
have like eight weeks or something the
animators
probably have less time I have two to
four weeks or something like that it
varies that was very different to how
things worked on the original three
series we're a team very much meant a
team it was supervisor and his team of
animators so let's recap right at the
top we have the supervising director
down from that we have the chief
animation supervisor but he's him we
have a number of talented animation
supervisors beneath each of those we
have even more key animators and beneath
them we have in-between artists the
reason most shows needs six to eight
months of pre-production is due to
scheduling and that is the most
important aspect of an animated show
like super that runs throughout the year
with no off season your schedule needs
to be healthy we need a healthy schedule
because each episode
ideally requires eight to eleven weeks
to create that's right I said eight to
eleven weeks each animation supervisor
usually is given an episode to work on
for a number of weeks with their
storyboard artist and a team of
animators which can vary they create an
episode out of practically nothing the
animation supervisor for episode 10 was
Osama Ishikawa we can see he worked in
Episode two here so that means that he
had eight weeks to create episode ten
the next episode he supervises after
this was episode 17 meaning he had seven
weeks to finish that particular one
assign each of these animation
supervisors an episode and we should
have a functioning schedule in theory
each supervisor working on an episode
two months in advance
submitting us on time and being assigned
another one right after to keep the
wheels rolling however this is where a
super imploded for lack of a better term
the first four episodes by enlarge were
produced to a satisfactory quality with
minor exceptions from Episode four
however fans of the show were shocked
and outraged with the release of episode
5 the animation supervisor for this
episode was now quítate his own
animation is on show in the episode as
well as the likes of kenan suka a key
animator who was responsible for this
fantastic cause in the episode however
parts which were scrutinized heavily
were cuts of animation like this clearly
unnamed animators rough animations
pushed forward to get the episode out on
time these are clear signs that toy
animations Dragon Ball super schedule
was
and so early into its lifespan this only
meant that things were going to get
worse to illustrate my point that this
wasn't the animators fault but instead
the time restraints they were under now
quítate the animation supervisor of the
episode had worked on Dragon Ball Z back
in the 1990's he is a senior animator
with over 20 years experience in the
industry the next episode he supervised
was episode 11 and was undoubtedly one
of the most well animated episodes in
the arc
despite fan outrage however the damage
had been done the powers that be rush
Dragon Ball super spree production not
allowing it time to create enough of an
episode buffer to produce quality
episodes consistently and it was only
going to get worse
I think Studio One pack is one of the
most transparent Studios who work on
Super they list their times on their
website and so as an example episode 23
aired on December 13th and it didn't
start production until December 1st
to help better illustrate my point here
is a very short animation of Goku
turning his head that I produced I use
the model sheets though he uses for goku
and i tried to stay as on model as i
could
this took me roughly nine hours to
produce let's see what it looks like
when i take only one hour to produce
this same animation sequence as you can
see there is a severe dip in quality but
as you saw earlier I am fully capable of
producing a satisfactory product however
when time is removed from the equation
the end result is compromised heavily a
youtuber an artist by the name of Mark
Crilley made a similar series on the
subject which if you are interested in
the process of illustration I highly
recommend you give it a look-see episode
28 aired on January 24 2016 this arc
served to introduce Goku universe 7 and
the audience to a whole new cast of
characters
these included Champa hit Kaba and vados
to name but a few
once Frieza had been defeated at the
hands of Goku in the arc prior a certain
amount of time has passed with the arc
kickin off during one of Lisa's training
sessions for Goku and Vegeta Champa
reunites with his brother and together
they agree to host a tournament if
beerus is universe 7 wins he gets the
super Dragon Balls orbs that when
gathered have no limit to what you can
wish for and if Champa wins he gets
universe sevens earth transported to his
they agree on a 5 vs. 5 tournament where
the winner stays on and thus was the
premise for the arc the first thing of
note in this arc was an improvement in
animation overall with the arc being 14
episodes in length none of the episodes
are animated particularly poorly which
might not seem like high praise and it's
not but considering the previous two
arcs overall quality this was a
noticeable and welcomed improvement
indicating that the show was heading in
the right direction as kind of Dragon
Balls retelling arc in a nutshell it was
just it was not good it looked bad it
was rushed it was amateur and then to
kind of solve that when it came to the
universe 6 arc they introduced like two
supervisors and so it was it was the
same amount of time that the work was
being divided up into blue hair
I thought they were yellow classic Goku
plane I'm gonna try this thing probably
won't work and if I fail then I'll die I
mean he's spending all this time
explaining what he just did but like
that whole time kayo Kane it's like
damaging his body okay I'm into that
that's pretty cool oh yeah yeah
then go we just powered through it by
being powerful I guess it is way better
though
definitely yeah right off the bat that
was much better
what was the deal with his blue hair
blue oh yeah
that's in the next series is that why he
was able to use the kaio-ken as well as
being super saiyan cuz I always thought
like when I was younger I always
reviewed on would be so cool of Goku and
K okay why he wasn't Super Saiyan yeah
what's that I had me grinning like an
idiot anyway yeah I didn't even know I
wanted this what did you guys think of
Goku's last fight during the universe 6
tournament well sauce when he was
fighting hit that was [ __ ] awesome I
was incredible and the me was I gonna
absolute I was very influenced for its
animation but I feel like the animation
of a lot of super up until recently like
even with like even after they got out
of the movies a lot of the animation in
the universe's X arc was very
hit-or-miss and it's been kind of very
kind of if he to say the least
oh it's much much better but the thing
is they they're not keeping consistent
like they're at there's movement where
so holy [ __ ] is this Dragonball and in
their moments like yeah that's right
well actually made me view it gave me
the vibe of Dragon Ball Z I was and I
love that cuz I missed it so much from
that because again it was the comedy and
that was a serious moment
and I'm laughs that they didn't make it
funny oh when you're on fire and no no I
joined I'm here
do you know when he did like the Super
Saiyan blue with the cocaine and that's
three beers I thought that was pretty
good yeah it was pretty much what I kind
of the way I see it now and this is
someone who'd like to completely [ __ ]
on educator and Dragon Ball Z is going
super saiyan was massive because they
did all of Dragon Ball where there was
nothing like that so somebody goes super
saiyan on na make it was a huge thing
and then going super saiyan 2 was kind
of even that extra it was the double
punch or the double whammy when everyone
to call us and I kind of feel after a
when Super Saiyan 3 I was like oh we're
just going to keep churning desires
aside from some minor hiccups the Ark
reached its conclusion as universe 7
defeated universe 6 with hit throwing
the final match against Menaka directly
following this act however we were
greeted by something we had not
witnessed in this series to this point
filler thanks to the internet many fans
now understood the purpose of these
types of episodes they were animation
light and easy to produce comparatively
to their story different counterparts
what did this mean for the series
something big okay now what is he in
blue hair what awful lot of blue in this
show name that is trunks isn't it
I thought he had purple hair
oh not big no did they just [ __ ] kill
turn it off I can't see any more of this
that was just sad
I'm his silhouette in the smoke it
really looked like Rioch for a second I
don't know how but it did I don't the
way the hair wasn't super evil like
triangular red eyes holy [ __ ] did they
just kill bomba I can see why he'd be
feeling blue come on
though the mother does baby the mother
has to die and then they just go berserk
what's about the blue now why isn't hair
Baloo fair enough I mean like puberty
hits it's all hard you think are you
really fast for trunks and black scared
the [ __ ] out of me
and then you see blacks face and you see
that it's Gokul you're like what the
[ __ ] is going on I think that the
animation has gotten a lot better I
don't really think that it's like top
tier in the whole like animation
industry it's certainly not that but I
think that just on its own separate for
everything else I think that it's
definitely gotten better than it has
before a June 12th 2016 episode 47 aired
for the first time for all to see the
episode received the highest rating in
this series up until this point it also
sported a new docker theme to the
delight of many fans across the globe
while reintroducing high stakes to the
world of Dragon Ball the premiere
episode also featured fantastic
animation by the talented now quítate
which helped raise Dragon Ball super
standards even higher the act covers the
events of trunks is last-ditch effort to
save his timeline from certain
destruction having taken care of the
androids cell and majin buu and his
timeline he witnesses the murder of his
mother bald
killed at the hands of a Goku look-alike
going by the name of black so this
present day your future well this guy
again I don't like him guys rocking off
this serious cocaine
what
is that one of the few nearing [ __ ] off
so we have like a Nega Goku now he's
like no I mean I thought it was really
cool I like that would definitely get me
interested in the storyline anyway
like you know what kind of puts the
first cliff you show me to shame where
was just like him jumping around this
purple cast missing punches in a single
shot I mean that it looked much nicer
you know my was she a character before
or was she made first Super he's like
I've literally never seen her before so
I was kind of like oh man she thought
she killed that thing with a shotgun but
like she thought that we'd do anything
that was class that would definitely get
me to watch the next episode stop at the
end o koku or whoever that guy is
that was unreal to be honest like it
have a really bad start and it took me a
while to get into it I think it was 60
episodes in what before I actually
revisited it because I remember you were
telling me about the tournament art and
I said oh there's some cool moments in
it so you see clips and selves I sort of
skipped the the first two arcs you know
and you used to go cooking so such a
happy childish character you would not
think that he would hurt a fly you know
and there you see him killing boma you
know it was it was [ __ ] traumatic you
the tension that creates I mean it kind
of reminds me of when the cell like he's
he's bass warm when he first appears
that tension that fear imposes it was
quite brilliant
quite brilliant done I think I think
what helped the series the most when it
hit the Future Trunks arc in the
animation improved quite a lot world
trigger had just ended and so we gained
new animators from there I think the
biggest person that we gained was
futoshi hakushi day who kind of
basically soloed that entire arc owns
one of the few people who could actually
animate action consistently throughout
the entire thing and that really helped
the MVP has been Shiro Miki as lamassu I
think he has been incredible he has not
that he carried that our real Haruka
wall was voicing Vegeta when he was
fighting against Goku blocking he
feeding him up and talking about you
just the fake saying and I just thought
that that was just a great moment I mean
the the moment where the ma su has Goku
against the wall and he tells him he
killed his kids and Goku goes crazy that
was very touching when Goku Black Hills
Bulma I mean these are I mean they're
not good moments these are terrifying
moments but they're memorable I'll never
forget that it should be evident at this
point the animation schedule I spoke
about earlier is in better standings
during this arc thanks in no small part
to conservative efforts toward the end
of the universe six arc and the quote
filler provided in between while the art
style leaves little to complain about
there were still shortcomings within the
son most obviously within the narrative
continuity in short the story itself was
compelling but toward the end it became
apparent that they had lost sense of
direction with it failing to make
coherent sense once they reached the
conclusion to go through the story of
this arc is a video into and of itself
which I am sure I will get to eventually
but just know that this had fundamental
problems which many fans notice the main
issue being sourced towards the last
episode of the arc surrounding its
conclusion with that said however the
Future Trunks or Goku black arc managed
to bring in the highest ratings in the
show's history and on November 6th 2016
Dragon Ball super surpassed Dragon Ball
GT in episodes a mere week prior to its
most climactic battle featuring vegeto
and merged the massive it never felt
right to me that sense of beans were
crunchy I don't know why like they don't
seem like they'd be crunchy fight that
lasts an hour and Dragon Ball time was
that like 50 episodes ok ah come here
what's happening with Goku black well
his situation
hijita and Goku [ __ ] that's class we
love the fusion half
there were just no limits to the show
I know buddy punches work in such a
weird way like they've already connected
but then they're like uh they could
think he's powering the punch like
that's not a punches work suppose it's
God 1 being weird is also fused the
animation here is incredible this is
really good
so he also has a lightsaber ok
such a lookalike now oh come on
cool animations like leaps and bounds
ahead like that I didn't notice any part
where I was a good how long I'm like I
don't know what the like I'm gonna call
in like keyblades like not like Kingdom
Hearts but like like where they could to
make swords out of their energy or
whatever like how long's up anything oh
it definitely improved we're you gonna
like it was well animated - I definitely
watch that stuff when they said we can
only fuse for an hour I'm like I
remember something that took five
minutes before that was a long time due
to merchandise sales I'll get to that
later and find enthusiasm surrounding
Dragonball on October 12th 2016 she way
she established an initiative called the
dragon ballroom
this dragon ballroom was essentially a
department created with the sole purpose
of making new Dragon Ball content
separate from toy animations Dragon Ball
super anime this would serve as the new
Dragon Ball mangas home ground from that
point onwards before the next and final
arc I will be covering in this video
toy animation produced 9 filler episodes
spending episode 69 through 78 and I
love them in these 9 episodes we get a
fun self-contained installment where a
Goku and Vegeta fighter all a who is
herself a Toriyama creation from his dr.
slump series we get a fantastic baseball
episode and a small 2 episode stint
where go ku is being hunted by hit the
assassin from universe 6 however it is
the 2 episode mini Ark with Goku and
krillen
I would like to talk about briefly if I
can episode 75 was by far and away my
favorite episode of these 9 fillers that
came her away why because it's story
board is a prime example of great
storyboarding the use of empty space and
zoomed away shots help get across to the
viewer how isolated and self-conscious
Crillon is without saying a word too
often an anime do we get blocks of
dialogue explaining what is going on in
characters heads and why we should be
invested in this scene and while that
isn't terrible I think it is at the very
least unnecessary when you can show this
to your audience instead
it's arguably the most beautiful episode
in the entire series at jump fest 2016
during the third weekend of December toy
released a promotional teaser video for
the upcoming new arc which is dubbed the
universe survival are more and more
information would make its way to the
public through online articles stream or
v-jump magazine all pointing to February
5th 2017 as the premiere of the new arc
what do you guys think of the universe
survival arc that's pretty good I like
all those episodes but I just feel like
it's kind of trying a long there's like
50 different fights going on at the same
time so like one episode will be on one
fighter and then like it'd be like
meanwhile so you've progressed like a
minute but you've watched like five
episodes but you've seen like five
different fights only a minutes passed
in the fight but went to the did the
other world to try to recruit Frieza and
I think that scene work really well and
whole episode as well just fear that the
way it pans out it's not it's not like
the previous ones word look it can
decide what I want to be the holy scenes
look uh it is very refreshing you know
it gave me hope that this series is it's
gonna get better from this now I do
think that there are some pretty good
moments in the universe survival arc so
far I think that kale is a pretty
interesting character I think that she's
she's definitely better than the
character she's based on I feel like she
has a more reasonable reason for kind of
going knots of anger I would say the
most fun I had watching an episode it
would have to be when kale went berserk
during the torment of power because that
was a complete nostalgia trip down
memory lane from a visual perspective
there was a certain change introduced
that viewers became abundantly aware of
as early as the first episodes airing a
new thick outline with a heavily
contrast the color palette had been
added to supers art direction the liners
you know the outlines how they kind of
blurred that out and they kind of give
you like the kind of effect where the
life is is really blurred I don't like
that that the line isn't strong it's not
really like it's not prominent you know
it's really blurred on that video
similar to the universe six ark which
saw the main cast take on a rival
universe the universe survival ark sees
our universe take on numerous others
however this iteration takes place in a
multi universe battle royal of sorts
pitting universe sevens ten best
warriors against the representatives
from seven other universes an
interesting concept which had yet to
have been done in the series and it just
so happens that this arc would be the
longest - as of making this video it
still has not reached its conclusion
currently standing at 35 episodes in
length as of October 15 2017 surpassing
the Future Trunks arc already by 14
episodes and eclipsing the first three
arcs which stood at roughly 14 episodes
apiece however while the promise of a
multi universe battle Royales sounded
interesting there was a lot of
groundwork needed for the occasion to
make sense to every viewer therefore the
first fourteen episodes of the arc would
be set aside to reintroduce the
characters that had been seldom seen in
the Dragon Ball super series up until
this point goku sets out and attempts to
find convince and recruit numerous
warriors from the show's long history
Krillin Tian Master Roshi Vegeta piccolo
Gohan majin buu 18 and for the first
time since the cell arc Android 17 makes
his dragon ball super debut when I heard
that piccolo and foo were gonna be in
the tournament I was thinking that oh
they're going to train with Bierce and
Lee's as well and they're gonna get
cocky and they're gonna be on their
level and it's going to be a more
interesting it's not just gonna be about
all who's stronger it's gonna be about
like the strengths and weaknesses of all
the characters different techniques and
I feel like that is they're kind of
doing that now with the universe
survival arc but I feel like they've
kind of done it a bit sloppily in just
how they've had characters just going
I've been training off-screen like what
training have you been doing to like get
on the level of gods on July 23rd 2017
Dragon Ball super aired its 100th
episode and achievement worthy of
commemorating for any long-standing TV
show Masako Nozawa who had been the
voice of Goku for well over 30 years
came out of the woodwork and released a
statement regarding the recent milestone
we hit 100 episodes in the blink of an
eye I was shocked when I heard about it
at this rate will probably reach 200
episodes in another eyeblink lately I've
been receiving messages at my house for
fans daily it makes me so high
my goal is for Dragon Ball super to
reach 700 episodes seven for the number
of Dragon Balls so all you fans keep
cheering me on is there anything that
you would like to change about the show
there's a there's a lot that I change
personally I personally feel at least
that they messed up a lot on the
handling of God ki Goku turns Super
Saiyan God and then it just all goes
back into his base form I personally
thought it would have been really
interesting if that like mess with his
Super Saiyan or something and so he's
just stuck in his base for him like you
know he shouldn't have like 13 different
forms that he can like pick and choose
from it should just be simply like he's
resting statement is powered up State
the other thing that I feel though is
while they have done this with Vegeta
and having him like get God key as well
I feel like they should have given God
key to a lot of the other characters
there's a reason why super is or what it
is like if you take out one element of
it there's it won't be as Dragon Ball as
it is so I mean that they're doing the
best they can with it so I am just going
to wait on to see or how the story turns
out before I make any judgments I don't
think so cause like if I changed
anything it would be Toriyama anymore
you know so I'd say just leave it the
way it is and polish off the animation
I think they should kind of bring you
there as a season rather than a
week-to-week thing because that kind of
makes it kind of boring like if they
brought out a season with twenty
episodes you'd be like oh it's all
building up to this one thing but then
nowadays they'd be like oh there's like
50 weeks of filler and then there's like
ten weeks of something that's really
good so like if they kind of compressed
it and knocked it a week week and did
like a season by season I think it'd be
more consistently good I like the fact
that there's a lot of lore building but
I'm gonna be honest with you I feel like
the lore building he's not gonna go
anywhere
I certainly hope it does but I feel like
we're being introduced to all these new
characters and universes and we're not
gonna get development for that many of
them my big issue with supe is that
everything feels self-contained
that doesn't feel like there's a big
adventure going on it's just a very
clear-cut
here's battle of gods his resurrection F
here's universe six here's Future Trunks
ugh here's the tournament ugh and it's
just that doesn't doesn't feel like a
natural flow between arcs and I think
one of the biggest examples for me is
between the copy Vegeta arc it just ends
and the next episode boom Future Trunks
arc starts and it's just like it's so
jarring it doesn't feel natural and when
it came to the end of the Future Trunks
are come we were leading ourselves
through all of the the mid arc filler
material but ever you want to call that
up to the universe of either luck it
just felt like a countdown it didn't
feel like we were building to anything
it was just like okay and the arc starts
now it just feels like movies still
having hit 100 episodes it has become
evident that Dragon Ball is not the
ratings giant that it once was in either
the west or the east in many ways this
is largely due to over saturation of the
market and the production of other
fantastic long and short running
franchises within the same genre when
Dragon Ball was released in the West
there was nothing else like it on
television and children across the globe
lapped it up nowadays shows with the
scale and scope of Dragon Ball our
numbering higher and higher each year so
it's no wonder the Japanese and Western
TV markets are not set on fire with the
return of Dragon Ball the ratings are
not bad by any means they're actually
quite good however the reason Dragon
Ball is receiving more and more backing
from to--a is down to one word
merchandising while Dragon Ball has
faltered in the anime Department and has
taken up right where it left off in the
merchandising section Dragon Ball was
and still is a merchandising juggernaut
looking at the licensing and sales
figures for the Dragon Ball franchise in
the mid-2000s it's clear to see that the
numbers were huge however in 2010 there
was a severe dip in the licensing
department reaching an all-time low in
2013 before the release of battle of
gods between 2013 and 2015
merchandising increased by almost 40%
with the release of Dragon Ball super
that figure took a large upswing placing
it into the realm of competition that
one piece occupies so at the moment
Dragon Ball super only has an upside in
the marketing department would you
recommend Dragon Ball super to a friend
if they are already a fan of Dragon Ball
I say maybe depending on like what
exactly it is that they like that they
like the series for I would recommend to
a friend that has already seen Brad
party but for someone who haven't seen
it yet oh if he was junghwa zi
guaranteed like bush i'd recommend they
watch Dragon Ball Z first if they
haven't and then I you know tell them to
give it a shot I'd let him know about
the animation for us you know so they
don't get shocked would be like leftover
why the [ __ ] are you into this you know
from early June to mid July I lived in
Osaka Japan it was on this trip I
started production on this documentary
my goal was to cover all the important
events of the series from its inception
to its 100th episode and I wanted to see
what Dragonball meant to as many people
as I could on one of my final days in
the country I decided to visit Universal
Studios Japan hearing that there was a
production celebrating showing jump in
the form of two 40 shows one for JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure and one for Dragon
Ball the real 4d experience is a
cinematic attraction at Universal
Studios Japan it depicts CG characters
engaging in monumental battles which are
projected in a theater within the park
and I gotta say everything about this
was fantastic from the greeters at the
gate to the music playing while waiting
in line it all served to further immerse
myself within the experience we filed
into the pack theater eagerly awaiting
the show's commencement I was skeptical
at first but by the end I was cheering
my hands miming along with the rest of
the audience as Goku requests or energy
to defeat the big bad of the feature
surrounded by all of these people of all
ages with their fingers pointing to the
sky I remembered what it was like to be
filled with that childlike excitement
cheering for my favorite characters on
the screen in this documentary I wanted
to chronicle what calls Dragon Ball
super to begin production as well as the
ups and downs the show has had thus far
I spoke to many different people from
all walks of life asking their opinion
on my favorite series and the answers
were very enlightening people seem to
enjoy and dislike certain aspects for
varying reasons some of the reasons were
technical and others were based on
feelings and that made me look back at
all the research I gathered our favorite
shows are not the ratings they receive
or the merchandise numbers they have
they are not complex animation sequences
videogames are money hungry executive
choices it's passion it's the excitement
the nostalgia the discovery the action
the sadness the goosebumps it's when one
man's passion helps them reach out to
millions of people and in some cases if
he's lucky it's when those millions of
people reach back
thanks for watching
how would you describe Dragon Ball super
in one word colorful do you want me to
be bothered
say what you like one word failure
sticks out to me purely for the
animation reason and funny you know if
you had to pick one I'd say positive and
say funny all right
it's not really one word I would say
kind of more of the same Jeremy liked it
that side from that first clip which was
like I after seeing it next to the other
ones this just [ __ ] atrocious but the
last kinda three clips you show me it
seems like it's very true to Dragon Ball
Z Joe I'd imagine if you liked Dragon
Ball Z or if you like Dragon Ball like
there's just more of the same to enjoy
in Dragon Ball super mixed anime I don't
know it's Dragon Ball one word it to it
it's - I'm super its it like it just
seems like trying ballsy again but like
more I guess somehow I don't know hey
fair enough thank you very much
thank you I thank you
in formal with the [ __ ] lights and
camera just take it a light take it
breezy yeah it like even even Kai like
its it's an anime so there's a lot of
[ __ ] in there I'm glad I didn't have
to watch Google Drive it sounds like
literally everything I would hate it's
like oh and like it's just I hear that
Japanese Goku is different but like it
encapsulates like English boys Goku
where it's like oh man I really like I
need a train to stop that thing that's
gonna destroy the world I'm out I want
to learn how to drive
oh man I'm hungry uh because he's an
anime protagonist he's hungry I feel
like I'm like this is gonna turn into a
porno audition tape it's super quick
also I hate Japanese Ground law Goku I
get that they're like you know it's like
oh you you know you've been with us
forever so you got to keep being Goku
ya know he just just Goku is in Japanese
grandma